hey what's going on it's Bill Burr it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast and
I'm just checking it oh you
who what's going on how is ya
how's your week going are you coping are
you checking in with yourself
are you living your best life
um
I followed this guy on [__] YouTube
he's great he does all this stuff about
like uh
what to look out for you know
maintenance and mechanics if they're
trying to rip you off he goes rev up
your engines and he really moves his
hand gesticulates if you will
when he talks
and uh
all of his videos are great and he did
one recently the guy was trying to claim
that these new Ford Lightnings are just
catching on fire and not only burning to
the ground but taking out entire parking
lots of cars
which I would think if that was actually
happening that would be like a bigger
story but there's you know there's also
footage of like uh oh there's electric
cars and they all caught on fire they
were on a boat coming over and they
burned the thing down it's like you
don't think maybe somebody on the ship
[__] up somehow there's also that
but whatever I just think the whole
thing's hilarious it's like I I wouldn't
even park next to an electric car the
parking lot is what they're trying to
say
and uh I'm just thinking to myself all
right but you're okay with riding around
with a tank of gas underneath you that's
then fed
you know past you
into an engine that's having a
controlled explosion
I mean
all cars are going to have problems is
that [__] there's no [__] way those
things are like burning he's like it's
got a back rub
Ford Motor Company
it was all this chicken little [__] man
it was I I don't know he did make me
feel good that I bought the F-250 with
the 6.7 turbo diesel I will tell you
that
um
I'll have to Google that it's always
funny like that you might have like
people that can't appreciate both
like I love a gas combustion engine and
I also love an electric car electric car
is the fastest [__]
um and I think they're getting better
looking
you know but let's be honest all cars
are kind of ugly now
generally speaking or or if they're good
looking they all kind of look the same
like BMW's Mercedes Jaguars all kind of
look the same
Toyota's Nissan Lexus all of that [__]
looks the same and then the American
cars all [__] look they used to be
you know when they weren't safe
I learned that doing uh
uh Comedians and Cars
with Seinfeld I asked them twice during
the episode why can't they make these
cool designs because there's too many
safety regulations
which is better you don't die in the
cars but like
back in the day man when they didn't
give a [__] if your head went through
the windshield the stuff they used to
design was gorgeous
but anyway I'm not [__] on that guy
by the way because I absolutely love him
and I love his passion for cars
and uh and I also love the intro rev up
your engines but I'll have to look into
that he could be right I don't know I
don't think that all the Ford Lightnings
are catching on fire
and I've also lived long enough that I
know of Something's selling well
in the car the automotive world there's
always immediately like a negative thing
attached to it to try to slow down the
sales like I always bring this up like a
long time ago they had this thing called
the Suzuki Samurai
um it was a little four-wheel drive like
a RAV4 type of thing but it was like a
Jeep where they would have like a soft
top and they just sold them as like fun
I remember the commercial they'd have
these fast cars going around the track
you know in the bank angle like 40
degrees you know almost [__] sideways
going around and then this Suzuki
Samurai would come out and they would
just they would drive up it in
four-wheel drive and then go back down
and everybody in the truck was going we
you know just like we're just having fun
in our vehicle blah blah blah blah and
that's what they sold it as a fun
vehicle that could you could go off-road
and have a mellow fun time and they were
selling like hotcakes because like
hotcakes bill yeah like hotcakes
I gotta look up where that expression
came from
um who doesn't like pancakes right and
uh but they were eaten into the sales
of of of the Jeep so then all of a
sudden there was this rumor going around
that the Suzuki Samurai was flipping
over and it was killing College age kids
and there was really no way to debunk it
back then
I mean it's hard enough now everybody
thinks I looked it up I just debunked it
it's like well how do you know the
information you got is real it's really
difficult with all of this information
but back then there was no way to tell
so people believed it myself included I
said well I heard those things flip over
right anyway long story short they it
[__] killed the car
the Suzuki Samurai and years later
uh I guess it was it was proven that the
Chrysler Corporation that was making
Jeeps
producing Jeeps were the ones that
started that rumor
so we'll have to see
but electric cars are here to stay and
like anything they'll have little
problems here or there and then they'll
fix them I mean Jesus Christ
I mean the amount of [__]
glitches that the gas combustion engines
cars have had over the years has been
countless recalls gas tank in the wrong
place causing fires state troopers
burning to death in a Crown Victoria
remember that [__]
and uh they they figure it out so um
but I was never afraid to park next to a
Crown Victoria
[Laughter]
so anyway I finished my my dates warming
up
getting ready to go back on the road I
did two nights at the Roxy which was
amazing because like I said Sam Kinison
uh
Sam Kinison taped
um
one of his his uh special I think right
after the uh
Rodney Dangerfield appearance I don't
think I remember I don't remember what
that one was called but it was taped at
the Roxy
and uh it's a really wild crowd
and
you know it was during the height the
[__] height of the Sunset Strip heavy
metal scene and all of that and Sam
could shred on guitar and I think he was
probably always going over there to see
shows it was right next to the Rainbow
Room
and um
I just I gotta be honest with I just
love the Simplicity of it
it's like you're living in LA and then
you tape your special in La is [__]
amazing to me because I always
seems like I always end up
on the other side of the country or or
[__]
I did one in England or whatever I'm
like what the [__] did I just do one in
LA
you know go right down the [__]
Street do it shoot it and then go home
would be pretty amazing I don't know why
I never think to do that
it's typical me but anyway so that was
the history there and then on Monday
night I got to do the troubadour
uh
which was another just crazy thing just
to pull up to the market you can see my
name on the outside of that thing it's
just the coolest thing ever and
obviously every [__] band I ever
loved
um that ever lived in La played there
and uh
it was a thrill to go on stage here so
thank you to everybody that came out and
now I got the real deal
I got Hershey Pennsylvania tonight then
I'm in Bridgeport Connecticut and then
I'm at the uh what used to be the
Continental Airlines Arena I think it's
now the Prudential Center
out there in uh New Jersey I'm doing
that on say
so uh I'm feeling really good about my
act and I'm in Minnesota right now man I
I would have gone out to the clubs but
uh
the game went into Extra Innings I went
to a Red Sox game they were playing the
twins of course they [__] lose
an extra innings walk off
single guy in second and third that was
it and um
but I got to go up in the booth for the
whole game
with uh
Kevin euclis and uh Dave O'Brien which
was really cool man
I still there was
that's not he I'll tell you it's not
easy all right hey go up there you just
[__] shoot the [__] but blah blah
blah it's like you really gotta be like
paid attention what's going on and like
somewhere around like the seventh or
eighth inning I just started like
glazing over
it's a lot to pay attention to trying to
figure out first of all I was
looking at the game down in the field I
didn't realize until like the eighth
inning I should be looking at the little
TV because they had all this information
and that Crane in my neck trying to
figure out how many outs there were and
all of that but I want to thank
everybody at Nelson
um
I had a great time uh
getting to do that so uh
so that's it I think that's what the
podcast is going to be you know me
talking conspiracy theories and just uh
thanking people for [__] this that
and the other
uh
got myself in decent shape for this
[__] tour I will tell you this man I
was stretching
because that's what you have to do as an
older person I'm stretching and I was
sitting down
and I didn't have a shirt on and I was
sitting down and I was just like what in
the [__] happened to me
so when I get back I gotta I gotta join
a gym
I need an elliptical back in my life
that's it
then I'll end up [__] wearing out my
hips and my goddamn knees and I'll have
to get [__] hip replacement surgery I
mean I don't know how you do what do you
do past 50.
you just [__] eat iceberg lettuce all
day and
sip on black coffee is that what you can
do I really think like it's part of
nature though
where they want to make sure that you're
aging out
you know no one finds you attractive
anymore and no one will [__] you
[Laughter]
because you're too old to reproduce
right but then on the other side you got
all this [__] plastic surgery and all
this [__]
I was kind of talking about that the
game tonight like these guys
from my generation that are just
absolutely [__] yoked shredded
and they're in their 50s and that if
it's there's no [__] way to do it
I mean how many chickens do you have to
eat you're gonna be like eating chicken
and steak as you're doing push-ups and
Nature's just like no no
now it's over it's [__] over shut it
down get some slippers put on some
pajama bottoms
this is [__] it right
my wife and I took a little stay
vacation like a year and a half ago
and I saw there was a guy
you know down at the pool without a
shirt on that was like
probably my age a little younger or
whatever and he was [__] jacked
and I said to me I go God damn I go
that's [__] inspiring man look at
that guy that guy is killing it
and he is going like yeah you know kind
of yeah
I go what he goes yeah he's got a little
she does that and she imitates like
putting a [__] syringe into your
[__] leg does that
and I was like really
she goes yes
Yes actually bug me because it made me
feel stupid because she was right
because this like
I don't know
I never really stopped working out and
I've never done any of that [__] and if
you see what the [__] I look like
without a shirt off versus this guy
you know but what do you build a [__]
Pinnacle of 55 year old beauty maybe
this guy is better genetics that's
possible but this guy like this guy
looked like like I wouldn't fight this
guy if I was 25 like that's how [__]
like it wasn't like uh roided up
but the guy was like solid like [__]
uh you know tapered in like that just
doesn't happen no loose skin
no no just uh God look at me I mean just
the fact he was in public without a
[__] shirt on
was amazing so
who knows I'm not going to talk too much
[__] about this because eventually we'll
probably will end up happening
is they'll have like
some sort of organic steroids
you know and the bread probably and of
course they'll be you know the only way
to get it to the masses
we'll have to they'll have to exploit
some group of people or whatever
I somehow I went down this [__]
rabbit hole
and uh I think as I was looking to think
about electric cars and all of that type
of [__]
and uh it's so funny because I I've been
sitting saying on the podcast going like
I don't understand
there's all of these people out there
that claim to be patriotic support the
troops and all of that [__] it's like
well you know and want to fight
terrorism well they say how like most
those terrorist groups they're funded by
oil money so it's like why don't you
drive in electric car it's my simplistic
brain
okay drive an electric car you use less
oil even though you know there's [__]
oil involved in electricity whatever
whatever you know
maybe lessen our dependency on it
and drive an electric car
then I go down this [__] rabbit hole
about where they get the materials they
get most of the materials from the
Republic Republic of Congo or whatever
and there's literally like slave
labor conditions they make like two
[__] dollars a day there's women down
there with like babies strapped to their
backs they're handling this
whatever this raw material is that they
need but there's no gloves or anything
and they're breathing this stuff in with
their baby and it's just like
Jesus Christ you just can't [__] you
can't win
you can't [__] win and that you can't
tell me there's no [__] way to turn a
profit on that [__] unless you treat
people like that I firmly believe it's
because the people at the top want to
give themselves a 100 million dollar
[__] bonus
um
I don't know well this has got
depressing didn't it so there's
basically no solution
so somebody told me he said if you want
to stay out of the depression of that
he told me this book and I actually
ordered it I was going to read the
[__] thing and I forgot to bring it
on this trip and it was something along
the lines of the purpose
of a man or the purpose of living your
life for whatever and it's written by a
holocaust Survivor
which is basically you know he said like
essentially the worst
level of human behavior and survived it
and then came out of it and then you're
just like
so like what like how do I believe in
anything because that would you know
that's why the person like suggested the
book to me because I kind of got into
this
you know place in my life where it's
like
I don't know you you got kids you want a
good a better world or whatever you want
people to be nice to each other and
you're trying to make decisions with the
least amount of people are getting hurt
in everywhere you go it's like nah [__]
you
oh you like that oh yeah they got babies
putting those together in [__] uh
North Korea what
yeah actual babies actual babies they
don't feed them they just make them work
and then they eventually starve to the
wow yes yes that's happening that's the
thing okay
you know obviously I'm [__]
exaggerated
so you got all that [__] horrible
[__] is happening
I don't know and then I don't know
I don't know what the [__] I'm saying I
went down this [__] road you know
what it is I just watched 10 [__]
Innings of baseball
it had to be mildly entertaining my
[__] brain is fried so now I'm
talking about slave labor in the Congo I
am so out of my element right now
um having said all of that
uh I've been really good lately I
haven't had a cigar and [__] forever
and I'm gonna when I get off this
podcast in exactly 13 minutes
if there is a cigar bar still open
I am not going to go to it because I'm
I'm already in my hotel room who's
kidding who
you know
I'm at that [__] age that once I get
back to the hotel room and I see the bed
it's it
I'm done
you know hey guys I'll head out with you
guys let me just go drop this off in the
room I see the bed and then it's just
like yeah I'm not [__] going out
we actually just got a new [__]
mattress
you know no we did not get an indochino
or a a Hazmat what the [__] is it called
I always I always never know how to
pronounce it because with an H
oh my God I can't remember they've been
only been sponsored my [__] podcast
forever
come on Bill you can do this
it's the name of a heavy metal band too
isn't it
I don't [__] know anyway
we didn't get that
because my wife my wife basically bought
a Craftmatic automatic adjustable bed
but it's the new version of it so the
whole [__] time I'm sitting there
going like
because she go I go oh
so like when you want to go up that I
have to go up too what if I don't want
to go up she's like no it's split down
the middle it's basically two twins
stuck together
speaking of the Nazis two twins stuck
together right and then they [__]
they
you can decide
you can decide what you want to do
so I'm like all right
all right that's
[Music]
that sounds okay
so she's so [__] excited about it
all right so I have to be excited about
it because I don't want to ruin her
excitement so I'm like okay
this is good so she gets it and it's
cool you know it puts your legs up or
whatever and every you know your head
goes up and all that [__]
so last night's the first night we have
it and I want to go to bed and it has
this massage
option on it where you can press the
button
and it does a massage it's not a [__]
massage it's just shaking the bed like
you're in some [__] whorehouse in the
1960s like the [__] honeymoon suite
when they'd have the hot tub the shape
of a [__]
heart you know and it's just jizz all
over the place from the last people
so
he goes try out the massage thing and
I'm just sitting there it's like all
right it's vibrating but
you know what it felt like it felt like
you know if you know what an earthquake
feels like
not like a bad one but there's always
those ones where you're laying in bed
going like
is the bed shaking
we have an earthquake is that an
earthquake like [__]
30 miles away so it's not really shaking
us is that what's happening and then you
go on the um sorry I get the hiccups and
I hate the worst [__] hot dog I've
ever had in my life this [__] thing
was on the rotisserie
since the beginning of the season
oh my God
and there's this bun and it wasn't even
sliced so I had to open it with my
fingers in the both tabs just came apart
and then just crumbs fell out the bottom
but I was starving right and yup in the
booth there's like no food so
I [__] bit into it
how can I explain it like the outside of
it it was like the outside was like made
out of wax like that was the kind of
crunch it had and then uh
I plowed through so anyway what am I
talking about Craftmatic automatic
adjustment adjustable bits right
so it just kind of goes like
there's a giant cat underneath you and
then you go to the next level
it gets louder and then like the last
level is like like really [__] loud
right
so I'm like
she's like how you feeling that I'm like
yeah it's all right it's I'm not into
that but I I like you know to be able to
put your head up and your legs up so I'm
I'm on board with this purchase
I think she did a good thing right
but then what happens is
is I want to go to sleep
so I bring my my side of the bed down
and then she still has the masseuse
thing on
and it's going
but it it's touching my mattress and I I
sleep on my side so my head's on the
pillow the pillow's on the mattress the
mattress is touching her mattress and
her mattress is vibrating
so now with my ear on the pillow it
sounds like she has it on the highest
[__] level
to the point I thought I had my side on
and I'm going is my side vibrating
and she was like in Bliss loving it
so now I gotta deal with this [__]
because she loves the [__] thing and
I don't know it's just one I'm thinking
can I put earplugs in but then like you
can have the ear plugs in it's going to
be even louder because your my body is
touching the thing that is vibrating
and if you actually put earplugs in at
that point you hear it inside of your
head and it's [__] louder and it's
like Jesus [__] Christ
so we'll see oh and then the last
problem is is the walls to our room are
[__] weird so the TV's off to the
left so now I got my [__] head craned
I'm folded up like a goddamn dumpling
and I got this [__] thing vibrating
but you know I love my wife to death and
I want to keep her happy and if you saw
how [__] excited she is for this bed
you know I'm gonna give it the uh
gonna give it the old College try here
but I'm gonna have to I mean what I'm
talking about on the podcast I'm
obviously I'm going to talk about it
with her before you guys hear this [__]
because it's Wednesday night I got to do
the call from the road here
um
I gotta let her know about that I'm
gonna say you know you know how you do
it I'm not saying I don't love the thing
that you bought I'm not saying I'm not
happy I'm not saying that I'm not giving
you credit for doing stuff for both of
us I'm just saying it sounds like
there's uh an elf with a [__] you
know with a jackhammer
you know maybe uh
he's got a little elf in driveway that
he needs to tear up and he decided to do
the work himself rather than [__]
hire a full-size person I don't know
I feel like I'm in Chicago and I got
that [__] apartment right next to the L
that's what I feel like
um I'm [__] around if you just saw
how [__] excited she was for it to
come and not only excited for it she was
excited for me and she wants me to love
it
and I I love it until it's making noise
so that's the only
it's gonna be like the only problem
well the other problem is is once you
[__] uh oh God she's gonna kill me
the other problem with the [__] thing
is
once you're up
you know
it's fine you feel like you're in the
hospital like you just got your appendix
out right who has a bed like this in the
house right so
sitting there
then you get used to it and then you
want to go to sleep and you [__]
you're laying it down the regular way
but your body is so used the other way
you feel like you're doing like a back
bend it's almost like I remember when I
was trying to get my instrument rating
when they would talk about like you know
if you were in the clouds and you were
in a hold when you you do that circle
like if you're banking
whatever 15 degrees for long enough
after a while that feels like straight
and levels so when you go back to
straight and level you now think you're
all the way over to the right or all the
way over to the left so you're [__]
over correct it's kind of like that
um but I also I only slept in it like
one night
um but I will tell you why I love the
bed though
why I love the bed is because my wife
[__] got so much joy out of it she
was so [__] excited
and uh you know and I love her I wanted
to be happy so as long as she's [__]
happy I could drill deal with this [__]
but I'm gonna I'm gonna have to deal
with the [__] Jack hammering
um
you know maybe because we didn't have we
didn't have sheets you know we didn't
have all the bedding like of course the
bed came and then the [__] sheets
come like the next day and by the way
she handled all of this [__]
I didn't have to handle any of it you
know I get the out you know whenever
[__] [__] gets delivered I'm always
on the back porch like I I spend
most of my time
on my back porch I [__]
I have meals out there
I write out there I edit [__] that I
shoot out there I just [__]
I love it you know I feel like if I'm
out there
you know I got the Solitude and then you
know
she's asking me to do something I can't
hear
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh you [__] better find this funny
because she's gonna get upset if she are
you saying you don't like it no I'm just
making jokes man
don't take it personally
um all right hang on a second what do I
got here
the live read everybody oh look oh Helix
Helix that's what it is
we didn't get that mattress we got a
Craftmatic automatic adjustable bread uh
simply safe buddy
um if you've listened to the show before
you've probably heard me talk about
Simply Safe you know they were named
best home security of 2023 by U.S news
and World Report so they're probably
resting on their Laurels right that's
probably what they're doing no they are
not definitely not they're always
innovating always working on the next
thing to help you and your loved ones uh
be safe 24 7. like their new two-in-one
smoke and CO detector
well what would cob
CDs carbon dioxide carbon monoxide
carbon dioxide
chief officer of detectors I don't know
uh it's next Generation Hazard detection
that distinguishes between fire and
cooking smoke so your home is protected
and you get fewer false alarms that's
cool the new smoke and CO detector
sensors join simply saves comprehensive
Suite of advanced security cameras
sensors and Hazard detectors for
seamless whole home monitoring with 24 7
Professional monitoring service trained
agents stand ready to respond to an
emergency
dispatching police firefighters or EMTs
to your door even if you're away or
can't be reached monitoring Services
costs one dollar a day simply says is is
easy to set up yourself or have a
certified technician install it for you
and there's no reason to wait with
financing through a firm you can secure
your home today and pay overtime in
installments that fit your budget right
now get 20 off your new system when you
sign up for interactive monitoring visit
simplysafe.com
um there's no safe like simply safe
all right everybody well once again I
want to thank neston and everybody for
letting me sit in the broadcast booth
for an entire game I can't believe I got
to do that the other times I've sat in
there I've only been able to be there
for a half an inning it's literally 20
minutes it goes by in like two seconds
um when I was a little boy and I used to
watch sports I used to think boy oh boy
I you know I'd love to be a broadcaster
I thought it was the coolest thing
because you got to go out of the games
you'd have like a great seat and all of
that so it was definitely a childhood
dream come true so thank you to
everybody over there
um Pennsylvania Hershey I'll see you
Bridgeport Connecticut you're next and
then I'll finish it up in New Jersey
there
um
if anybody knows a good spot to get
coffee in uh
uh because I'm not I'm not gonna go get
a cigar ah [__] it
I'm not gonna do that so what else what
else do I have left I have [__]
drinking coffee I hate these [__]
[__] goddamn machines here
that they have in the hotel rooms with
the little shot
all like the multi-colored [__] shot
here like what is they don't even tell
you how to use the damn thing
says Coffee mate the original and then
they got these colored ones I don't even
know what this is the original what
shake well
oh that's cream and then these are the
coffees this different colored ones blue
gold and brown so what are those are the
some of those decaf if I take them out
do I automatically get charged
I can't even read this [__] what does it
say
it says recycle
oh it's in French
and it says Tokyo
Lango I don't even know what the what is
this [__] [__] I'm not doing this
little packets of sugar is that cocaine
um all right I'm not doing this okay I'm
going to bed enjoy the music picked out
by the wonderfully talented Andrew
femalis and then we have a bonus episode
of the Thursday
um
or the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday Morning podcast that's it
I'll see us
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday over there it's uh June 22nd
and I am in Santa Rosa Santo Rosa where
they makes the one you know they say
um California Santa Rosa and um
last night I performed
I don't even know I can't remember the
name of the venue the Wells Fargo oh ho
the Wells Fargo wagon is uh I can't even
look it up on my website because my
[__] website the second I do the gig
he's like go [__] yourself it's over
that information no longer exists wait a
second let me look me up here
let me look me up oh God he's in his ego
this week basically I would give a [__]
what the name of the thing was
um
the venue I played last night was the uh
the venue George Carlin did his last
stand-up special in
um
someone I thought someone told me that
this was the place where he did his last
show it was the Wells Fargo Center for
the ads
um this is the place where he did
um his recorded his last special
and his last performance was at the
Orleans Casino in Las Vegas if you're a
George Carlin nut like me
um
so last night I was
I was standing backstage and I don't
know man it was really [__] cool it
was such a
um an amazing venue it had like the
lower level and then I had like this
this small upper deck that just wrapped
around
you know
all three sides that I was looking out
at it looked like a minor league
Ballpark and the crowd was I could tell
when bartnick went out there
they were uh
they were just a really smart crowd and
I had one of my best shows of the
[__] tour so I really want to thank
everyone that came out last night and um
you know it was a good time I don't know
who knows I [__] I ended up staying on
the up to like four in the morning
with [__] bartnik I'm watching full
metal jacket and drinking this wine
because you know we're in Wine Country
so they're just giving us this [__]
wine and we're drinking it and I have
the worst goddamn hangover I [__]
I appreciate why but wine should only be
drank with like a good meal
you know what I mean
somehow women can drink it I don't know
how the [__] they do it you know around
4 4 30 when I really just can't deal
with their [__] kids anymore they
just you know they pop in a DVD you know
okay go watch SpongeBob takes over
[__] Japan whatever the [__] they're
doing right
SpongeBob vs Pokemon come on kids
you know
this was just sit out and then they just
[__] they just start boozing
which I totally respect
I don't know how the [__] they do it
though man it's a brutal hangover so I'm
like all right the bus isn't we're not
leaving until 11 in the morning
you know so I stayed up till like
four in the morning in the back of my
head it's like well I gotta do my
podcast it's like ah no big deal I'll do
it on the bus and I'll just [__]
upload it and uh
at like [__] 8 30 in the morning the
people staying in the room next to me
they have these two little kids like
real young those [__] kids were up at
the crack of dawn
and one of them was you know there's a
door between my hotel room and the other
one and one of them with his little baby
hand was just slapping the door
you know talking gibberish
just slap slap but you can't get mad at
a baby
you know what I mean
I mean I guess some people do you know
that doesn't usually end up well
I think babies are pretty much uh
they've yet to win
in a fight with an adult you know what I
mean they're like the 1977
[Music]
[__] Tampa Bay Buccaneers that just
went oh and 14.
you know I don't know what it is with
babies they they really got to turn it
around
when they're fighting adults they gotta
somehow uh
they've got to change the culture
you know in that nursery and somehow try
to get out there and try and find a way
to win
you know because I'll tell you right now
you know if they keep doing what they're
doing you know they're never going to
beat an adult
you like that that I went into I went
into Mike Golic there
yeah they could cry
so um it's on [__] real just kids
just [__] wake up and they
they don't even have to stretch you know
what I mean like before I get out of bed
I swear to God if I just lay down and
watch TV for 20 minutes if I get out of
bed I feel like I haven't walked in nine
years
like I before I get out of bed I
literally have to take my [__] toes
and point them at my knees and hold it
there for like [__] it it felt like a
good 30 seconds then I get up I'm fine
if I don't do that if I just get up and
start walking I do that you know you
take that one and a half steps and it
you do that little [__] quick little
like somebody just kicked you in the
side of the leg you go oh [__] you know
and I have to stop putting my hands down
on the mattress and then stretch out my
[__]
whatever it is my Achilles
kids just get up and run man
you know
I swear to God if I is it illegal to get
your baby drunk
you know just so it'll sleep longer when
it wakes up it's just it's just gonna
lay the like ah [__] you know
oh [__] time
let me just lay here let me just lay
here for another 20 minutes you know
that's what I would do if I had a baby I
would just get it hammered big time
drink up you know I put a redness
formula is that illegal
you know I know you're not allowed to
drink publicly until you're 18 but if
you're with your parent or a legal
guardian can't you get [__] up
together
I'm seriously asking you that
you know
what if it's why you know you make it
sophisticated like whatever like
like if you have like one of those
Gerber ones if it's a lighter color do
you go with the white wine for the baby
and then if it's like one of those ones
that has beets in it you get them a red
or is that redundant
is that vulgar
to have uh uh that two colors on top of
each other I have no idea and I have no
idea I'm not sophisticated like like you
[__] wine drinkers
you know
somebody's got to be do I know obviously
I know that's [__] illegal but
somebody's out there has got to be doing
it
you know like Jesus Christ
it's like if you're a night owl and your
kid just wakes up at six in the morning
something has to give
you know
didn't they used to do that when babies
were teething
they pour little booze into their milk
or something like that or do they rub it
right on their gums
you know like the kids some [__] cop
trying to determine whether it's cocaine
or not
you know they always do that in the
[__] TV shows and the movies where
they're like they're like what do you
got there Mike and he goes you know he
does a little little tap tap tap and he
critics
yeah this is the real deal
you know
oh he's crying
poor thing
whenever you're a baby cry I just stop
[__] it always makes me laugh I
always just think like you know what
dude I hear you
I want to do that too
I wish I could still cry like that the
way a baby does just over little things
I think I wouldn't even be angry anymore
he said you just get it out of you you
know
if I go to turn on my phone and I find
out that I didn't recharge it the night
before and it's completely dead you know
rather than be like [__] goddamn
[__] idiot Bill what if I just went
[Music]
he just [__] cried it out
oh my God how much would your wife
[__] freak out if you just started
doing that
I wish I could do it for real you know
just as a joke with me and just tell her
that I [__] I'm reading this new book
on crying it out
and just see how long I could sustain it
I didn't think I could cry once you'd
just be like what the [__] are you doing
you know what I mean
and then I would just cry and walk like
you know what baby does when you yell at
it
I don't know what it is
babies just [__] make me laugh no
matter what they're doing
like you ever see those psychos like
when you're on a [__] plane
I feel like I just keep going like what
if this happened like did you ever have
this happen like why am I talking I
gotta do it again instead of saying like
why am I talking as if I'm a seventh
grade girl chewing gum
you know why because I went to bed at
like 4 30 in the morning
that's why so you're gonna have to deal
with it oh Billy teeny bopper here this
week
um whenever I'm on a [__] plane
and a baby starts crying
whenever I see people like those people
who get angry
like oh they put on their [__] bows
uh noise canceling things
you know I always feel like anybody who
has the money to buy headphones that all
they do is just block out the sound of
other people it's just like
there's only the only way you could do
that is if you uh you had like blood
Money
who's got the money for Bose [__]
they're like 300 dollars
and all they do is just block out people
talking
it actually sounds great if I had a
[__] pair of those on right now
then I wouldn't hear those kids crying I
don't know what it is
no idea anyways what I'm trying to say
is Happy Father's Day everybody
happy belated Father's Day
you know did you get your dad a man
great so he knows that you care
you know
man Great's [__] hilarious they just
advertise once a year like your dad only
wants Steakhouse quality once a [__]
once a year
that's it you know I called up uh
a bunch of my friends who were dads
and I was just like hey you know Happy
Father's Day
what are you doing today and they'll be
like oh you know I'm working in the yard
I don't know you know I'm [__] uh I'm
putting up a shelf or something I'm like
no what are you doing you know for your
your sort of
birthday here it's Father's Day
in every one of them just it was just
one shitty thing after another it's like
none of you guys are going out to like a
teddy bar none of you going to a ball
game
you're just out in the [__] yard
I don't know what the I don't get that
you know Mother's Day don't you take her
out for little eggs benedict
you get her some flowers
I don't know I feel bad for the dads out
there
what could you do you know
even if there's a stake I mean God God
knows you got to go out and go make it
right
unless you're Paul verzie Paul verzie
doesn't [__] with his grill
it's unreal I went over his house one
time you know we were having burgers
and he didn't even make them
you can't have that man you can't have
somebody else man in your [__] Grill
I mean what happens next you know
even let a man come over your house and
he cooks on your grill and you're not
cooking on it I mean within five minutes
he's going to be slow dancing with your
wife
you can't I don't even care
if you suck at it I mean it's not that
hard get good at it right
just make a couple of burgers
some hot dogs
Jesus Christ Mercy
um
you know what's funny is later on today
I'll be like uh dude did you say I
didn't cook on my eye don't I [__]
cooked on my no you didn't you didn't
um anyways this is the Monday morning
podcast as we're working our way through
June
um me and Barton bartnick is absolutely
[__] destroying
in front of me man it's great it's
making me have better sets because uh
students bringing the Heat
he's bringing the fire
um
he's just one of my favorite Comics I'm
gonna leave it that the [__] guy just
it's it's his act is just so blunt and
even when he talks
he just gets right to it and uh I can't
even say half the [__] he says because
it's so [__] politically correct
but he talked to me about I forget he's
working someplace in some biker
came in with all his biker buddies and
then one of them peeled off and wanted
to go into this room
and Joe was like yeah you can't go in
here and the guy was like oh I can't go
in there and Joe just Joe has a way of
like uh
you know just get having a look on his
face where all the emotion goes away and
it makes your [__] blood run cold so
he's telling the story and he goes the
biker goes oh I can't go in there and
then Joe just makes that face and goes
no you can't go in there and he said him
and the biker guy were staring at each
other and then the biker dude back down
and he was just like all I was thinking
was uh
you know hey dude I can go back to
Pittsburgh
and make pizzas
while you [__] biker friends are
putting you in the ground
I left out a couple of words
um
oh my God he said that [__] and I think
I came up with the [__] we were it was
me and somebody else just were [__]
crying laughing
and Joe's sitting there still deadpan
like what like he went into that mindset
I don't think I've ever thought I had
thought
I don't remember a time
anybody threatened my life but if they
had that look on on their face that Joe
had there's no [__] way I wouldn't I
would back down too I'd be like oh okay
see you later
walking with my biker jacket over my
forearm like a gentleman you know
Jesus Christ people got tattoos in
Northern California
my God
I saw this woman she was so tatted up
she went all the way up her neck and
then like you know when they go beyond
the neck but not quite their face
what is that part of your face
between your neck and your chin it's
like the taint of your face you know is
that all I mean your chin is that thing
right in the front right Jesus Christ
Bill take an anatomy class oh [__] you
what is that what is he underneath there
is that still part of the neck or is
that part of the chin
what would you say you put the gun right
under his [__] chin yeah I guess
that's be a chin
right I don't [__] know anyways she
was tatted right up
to where if you had a cleft chin it
stopped there and right along
her face too you know like when someone
has a really neatly trimmed beard
it literally looked like
she was slowly drowning in tattoos
like if you stared at her long enough it
was going to move up another inch and
she was going to start panicking
worrying if she was still going to be
able to breathe
um
you know what really is normal now is
actually to have a tattoo on your face
it's not as shocking
the only time he used to see it was back
in the day when you watched National
Geographic and there's some tribe down
in
South America they just draw all over
each other's face
you know worse than like prison tattoos
it looks like Morse code
you know or like uh well you remember
those things you had before there was
the internet you had crossword puzzles
and mazes
get through the Maze and you drew like a
pencil on it so they just like to draw a
maze on their [__] face
um
I just saw a lot like chicks with just
[__] Giant
pieces I believe them they call them
all up and down their their arms
it's like everybody out here plays in
Good Charlotte or something I don't I
don't understand it they're great people
good looking people too good looking
broads up here in Northern California I
got to get you this uh I know I'm all
over the place I don't give a [__] I
gotta get you this this picture this guy
[Music]
um
who had a tattoo of his baby's face put
on the side of his face
in in
like part of it like went in covered up
part of his ear
like where the and then it was also
really dark I didn't get it I mean it
was a white baby it's like why is this
thing so dark it was like it looked like
a baby that was like like if it was me
as a baby
but for some I don't know a kid stuck
his head in the fireplace it's like just
the worst
it's the worst [__] tattoo I've ever
seen in my life and this guy's going to
check it out man check out my new ink
man let me look at this man puts tattoo
I saw it on Facebook I love
I love Facebook man
that's when you know you're old when you
like Facebook and all the kids like uh
fluking Facebook's so lame good get out
of here you [__] punk I want you
around here anyways you dumb stories
thinking you lived life you haven't all
right you [__] dope I'm actually that
old now when I look at people in their
20s like college age kids and I just
think God what a bunch of [__] dopes
when they drink the way they behave
I used to think I was a maniac dude I'm
[__] crazy it's like no I wasn't I
was some nerd who couldn't handle the
freedom of not being around his parents
anymore
is experiencing that for the first time
oh I'm gonna get drunk and jump off
something so that chick over there
thinks I'm I'm funny or crazy and then
maybe she'll blow me like really bill
that was your game plan
all right man puts tattoo of baby's face
on his face
probably like 20 different pictures of
some dummy doing this there it is
there it is
yeah and he's holding his baby
he's got a white baby
and this this baby looks like I don't
know it's weird it looks like the baby
is uh coming out of a fireplace
you know face maybe a little on fire
what a [__]
why would you do that
where could that guy get he couldn't
even get a job in a [__] Nursery like
look look how much I love babies but no
not in a sexual way you know Jesus I
just yelled that and they have babies
next door I hope they can't hear me of
course they can hear you Bill their kids
aren't yelling that loud you can hear
them
right
not Jesus
well this would be my evidence right if
they came in why are you talking about
uh
I can't remember what the [__] I just
said oh not in a sexual way why are you
talking about babies in a sexual way I'm
like no I actually did a podcast officer
here listen to it and then he takes my
device and just erases it
some crooked cop
all right I don't know what the [__] I'm
talking about here
um
all right we're about 19 minutes in I
think it's time to listen to Bill read
out loud what do you guys think huh what
do you think
all right hey my batteries died so I had
to go to the front desk and go get some
more batteries battery level high that's
what the recorder says because he has
the English lady in there because it
makes your device more classy
so this uh you know
lady Butler that's in my recorder kept
going battery level medium
so I'm thinking let's go you know all
right well I don't have to worry about
anything until [__] Queen Elizabeth
goes battery level low and then I was
gonna buy batteries but this ship went
from battery level high to battery level
medium to just shutting off you know
what I mean
that's like when somebody you know just
gets divorced out of [__] nowhere
like I thought they were getting along
great I don't know we just we decided to
go our separate ways
did you
well that's good good for you good on
you all right so anyways let's get to
the uh let's listen to me read out loud
oh here we go we'll get to that one
later
um
all right what else did I want to talk
about this week
I by the way I
the horrible tragedy
that douchebag shooting up the uh
the church can somebody please explain
to me
I don't understand this as a white
person why are white people trying to
act like that wasn't a racist Act
I mean did he have to have I'm a racist
tattooed across this [__] forehead
what what else why why I just
I hate when people [__]
they look at their race like it's a team
you know what I mean it's like me when I
defend Tom Brady and you guys all go oh
if it was on the other [__] way you
know Andrew Luck did it you'd be
[__] on him right I'd like to think
I wouldn't be but people do that with
like race so because like they're saying
this racist white dude is racist then
somehow they're saying you're racist
they're not saying you're racist you're
[__] [__] he's a racist
and white people stop [__] acting
like you don't know racist white people
you know that guy at the cookout who
Auto gets a couple beers in him and
starts dropping the n-word and then you
gotta be like hey hey take it easy come
on come on huh trying to have a good
time here right that [__] guy and
then hopefully you don't ever invite him
again why are you acting like those
[__] people don't exist you know that
that guy's a racist that you [__]
cookout and all he did was drop the
n-word while he was eating a
cheeseburger this [__] guy went into
that church specifically to kill black
people because he hated black people I
mean what what the [__] more do you need
there was like nine shows
if I had any hair left I would have tore
it out watching him going what the [__]
are you trying to defend sorry none of
that was funny but it was [__] true
um anyways
getting back to uh the podcast here I
saw this article on uh of Jesus did I
get rid of it where is it there it is
this [__] guy who's who's evidently
the 970th
member of Guns and Roses
and I know even though I'm making fun of
that [__] band you know I'm not even
making fun of the band like the
musicians think it's just the fact that
they're still calling it Guns and Roses
right
that would be like if you bought
McDonald's and you filed you fired that
[__] clown and you're still going
yeah and you fired the Grimace and the
Hamburglar and you got ripped mayor MC
cheese none of them were there anymore
but like uh I don't know the [__] one
of them one of the Grimace stuck around
no you know what Ronald McDonald did
because Axel is a [__] redhead
um
and you're still acting like it's this
Band of Brothers whatever so anyways
there's this article
by um the 9000th guitarist and guitarist
the guys DJ ashba and it says DJ aspa
Guns N Roses guitarist DJ ashba claims
his aunt and uncle invented technology
for aerosol cancer
all right uh guns and roses and 6 a.m
Nikki sixes band guitarist DJ ashbo was
interviewed by Sweetwater editorial
director Mitch Gallagher
here's what he said ashba says who owns
a company centered around media and
advertising that runs various other
countries was asked what takes them in
those directions he responds now
basically they wrote exactly what he
said so I'm gonna maybe [__] up the
emotion of this thing but basically he
said you know I don't know I've always
had that creative bone my aunt and uncle
invented the technology for aerosol cans
so ever since I was young
dot dot dot they came out with the
product when I was really young called
Pam that's like a buttery spray and I've
always kind of grew up in that
environment I thought outside the box
and it really taught me that it's better
to create your own job than to work nine
to five so that's what's always been my
mindset I just love creating ashba also
talked about his belief that musicians
should diversify and have a backup plan
he said I absolutely will always stand
by that if you put all your eggs in one
basket all you got to do is drop them
and they're gonna break and every one of
them will break but the whole thing dot
dot dot and I've learned this from 6 a.m
bandmate Nikki Sixx it's like you set up
buckets you set up buckets little
incomes coming in there there there
there and as a whole that's how you you
know with this one Jesus Christ this is
getting difficult if three buckets
aren't doing well this month but the
other ones are you're going to be fine
so it's diversifying but if you put all
your eggs in one bucket and you have
five months of you know things aren't
going that well that could spill all
your eggs right now what the [__] guy
said in there I'm telling you is the key
to freedom and making your money work
for yourself so I'm looking at the
comments and everybody's just [__]
on them next thing you know he'll be
telling us he invented whippets
someone wrote so the [__] what I guess
that's some new cool way of saying what
the [__] and somebody wrote any invented
huffing aerosol cans
uh I would like to salute Auntie and
Uncle ashba for making it possible for
me to get high on the cheap during my
turbulent and Troublesome teen years
uh
buy a real shirt
so is aunt and uncle are responsible for
the deaths of countless insects for
screwing up the ozone layer and even
worse for all the horrible hairstyles of
the 80s congrats
someone writes this guy is the ultimate
poser
it's
it everybody just shits all over them
now I don't think he really [__]
meant air so I think he just invented
Pam I don't know what but in the middle
of all that
he said
some brilliant [__] about this guy's
made it as a guitarist right but then
he's starting his business on the side
with the money that he's made so if the
next album doesn't do well his business
is doing well
and there's this thing
in in you know I found being a comedian
people always say that hey you know if
you have a [__] backup plan you're
not going to go 100 as a comedian and I
kind of bought into that after you know
you know early on but the reality is
is you can make all this money as a
comedian as a guitarist is whatever
you're doing but then you can take that
money and start other [__]
you know I got this stupid ass podcast I
got some money coming in from the
[__] advertising I do my stand up I
got money coming in from that
and now I'm I'm looking at okay maybe
I'll take this money and go buy an
apartment building and become a [__]
slumlord and then when I'm in like 70 if
I own enough of those [__] things I
don't have to go on the road or people
are just like oh these fat old freckled
[__] he's been talking about the same
[__] for 50 years [__] him and I go back
down to plane in front of 30 people I
can still do it because I love it but I
won't become destitute
and this guy is like giving you this
information for [__] free and
everybody just shits all over them
I don't know
I found it really uh really inspiring
and um a combination of that and I also
um
I was reading this thing I'm gonna [__]
up the guy's name I think his name is
Nick Offerman that guy from that show
um
you know where every parks and recs the
guy looks like an older Zach
Galifianakis
you know he's funny he's [__] hell he
does a lot of voice over cartoon [__]
why don't you just look it up Bill cause
you know what I got my [__] hands
full right now I'm holding the recorder
and I got my phone but he had this great
article
and
I'm going to read this to you guys here
it said what what is the best advice you
ever received and he said I had this
amazing teacher in college my sensei in
the Kabuki theater and I thought that
that was when the women you know [__]
put on the makeup right and they gave
you a hand job in the end I have no
[__] idea anyways
um name
shozo Sato it probably [__] up his
name for me he was between Mr Miyagi and
Obi-Wan Kenobi he told me to always
maintain the attitude of a student no
matter how old you are wake up in the
morning and think okay how am I going to
better myself am I going to improve my
French am I going to give my wife a good
back rub then you can go to bed having
tried something
it's led to a life that is more fruitful
than if you have the mindset of being a
master once you think you're the master
then you grow bitter waiting for someone
to throw you a parade because you're so
[__] smart he didn't say [__]
smart but
those two things right there right there
you know what I mean
I hope you got something out of that I
have no [__] idea
but um
that's the way you should go about if
you play guitar whatever the [__] you do
if you think that yeah dude I'm the [__]
then you stop growing and then these
Young Bucks Run you down
I'm basically saying people that even
though I can tell a [__] joke at the
level that I can I never stop trying to
find a better way to tell that [__] joke
what if I squatted down and really tried
to take a [__] on stage I mean those are
the kinds of things
I'm making fun of it but I really got
inspired by both of those things so
there you go now I can't always be
sitting here on the podcast screaming
[__] can I all right let's add let's do
some adding here I did 19 minutes and 17
19 and 17 is [__] 38 minutes all
right I got another 22 here to go
um
all right what the [__] was I that I
want to talk about here oh so we went to
Reno
the biggest little town in America
and uh that was one of the rowdiest
[__] crowds I performed in front of
in a long time and
it kind of surprised me because the last
time I came to Reno they weren't like
that but what happened was this week
pulled in
Torino which I [__] love that city
right we pulled in
and we just see all these people in the
street they had closed off the street we
had to try to figure out how to get the
bus around and uh they had this Festival
out there it was Brews blues and BBQ
they should have said BBQs you know like
you're getting more than one barbecue
just so it Rhymes bruised blues and BBQs
but it was blue Brews blues and BBQ and
I swear to God
this [__] show that was walking around
out in the sun the tattooed [__] [__]
show of people walking around hammered
you know parents who let their [__]
in-laws watch the kids and they're down
there sunburned booze and eat and
barbecue me and bartnik immediately were
just like oh this barbecue we gotta
[__] go
and we go down there and people were
[__] shit-faced well on their way to
getting shit-faced I saw some lady in
the sun right sitting at this table with
their head down
like you know remember when you came in
from outdoor recess and everybody was
all amped up from the sugar and salt
you'd put in your body stirring lunch
and you came in and the teacher would be
like all right everybody put your heads
down on the desk
let's just take a little nap here let's
[__] relax so you're not bouncing off
the walls as I try to teach you some
phonics here that's what she looked like
and she was I mean there was like two in
the afternoon
so me and bartnick are going like all
right let's get some barbecue took us
forever to find out where it was and
then when we found it it had this
ridiculously long line and botniks look
at me going dude I don't want to [__]
stand in that line and I was like yeah
[__] that let's not stand but then it
seemed to be moving so we were like [__]
it
so we stood in the line and uh the
barbecue was unbelievable
one of the best briskets I ever had and
I was sitting there going all right I've
been eating right I've been doing cardio
every day
um let's just pick one meat
all right either get the ribs to pull
pork or the [__] brisket and uh you
know I was starving so you know how that
goes
you get up there and your brain is
telling you you know
just get the pulled pork or just get the
ribs you know but the demon the sugar
salt demon that's running through your
veins goes get all three and who do you
give into you give into the addiction so
I go all right let me get let me get all
three and some coleslaw and one of those
little [__] jalapeno cornbread things
so um
we [__] you know I'm in front of
bartnik I get all my [__] and I get a
lemonade and I see this table where
there's two people already sitting there
but there's an umbrella and some shade
and you know I'm a redhead so I'm one
degree away from a [__] albino so I
B-Line towards that and I sit down I
said hey do you guys mind if we sit here
and this guy's like you know the cost
you [__] eight bucks
that's crazy [__] laugh and he's
missing number eight
okay you got two teeth down front eight
and nine going from right to left
um he was missing number eight no I'm
sorry number nine he was facing me sorry
it's my dental office days and I didn't
give a [__] I was just I rolled with
dead jokes
you know I was like all right man I'll
give it to you in a check he goes no I'm
kidding I'm kidding it's only six bucks
[__] crazy laugh missing a tooth and
at that point bartnick sits down and
he's got that I'm gonna murder a biker
look on his face and he just looks at me
and he goes and they're like trying to
joke with him and he completely ignores
him and he looks at me and he goes
there's a tent over there
and I go oh oh yeah and because now it's
all awkward because he's not interacting
with these people who are hammered
telling the worst jokes ever and I'm
pretending like they're funny and Joe
goes there's a tent right over there and
I just go oh oh you want to go sit over
there instead and he goes yeah and he
stands up so then I like a little kid
could just go okay guys see you and I
walked over there I started laughing I
go Jesus Christ and he goes and he just
goes botnik does this thing where he
just sort of puts his hand up one of his
hands up he goes dude I want to enjoy my
meal okay I don't want to sit there talk
to her dad what did he call them methy
or something like that with this missing
tooth I just want to sit here and enjoy
it and then we sat down at this other
[__] table and it was actually great
we actually where we sat
there was like a breeze and all this
thing
um and the [__] barbecue was
delicious
and um I looked across the parking lot
and there was this little coffee shop
little tiny coffee shop looked like
there was enough room in there for
someone to stand and have a coffee maker
little coffee shop and you know it was
called it was called Pony expresso
and my wife loves wordplay so
immediately I took a picture of it and I
called her up
you know and I've been on the road for a
little while so she gets a little grumpy
when I'm gone that long
um which is funny because when I get
home then she gets grumpy when I'm home
for five days I'm a really annoying
person that's what I'm trying to tell
you so I called her up and I told her
that joke and she [__] lost it I
don't know why she loves word play but
it's my one of my favorite things to do
is when I see some dumb word play
business sign I call her up
and every once in a while something gets
her and she likes horses and she thinks
Ponies are cute and she just thought it
was the cutest name ever and she [__]
laughs for like five minutes
making me laugh as I'm sitting there
devouring the barbecue it might have
been the best moment of the tour so
anyways
you'd think having done stand up for 23
[__] years
I would have done the math and realized
that this sunburn tattooed missing tooth
[__] show that was already drinking four
hours before my show was gonna start
some of them
some of those animals were gonna [__]
come into the show it never dawned on me
and I went out on stage it was one of
those things as a comic you come walking
out on stage and you just feel the vibe
like all right why do I feel like I'm in
a saloon in the 1800s and I think I said
one thing and somebody yelled
from the to the left I don't know if
that stage left or stage right I never
know how the [__] that works
and just right out of the gate it's like
Jesus Christ I didn't get a [__] word
out
so I riffed something about how they had
this person had horrible parents and
that's why this person was behaving this
way and um
and then that was basically the end of
the show I had engaged with them so now
it just became a totally interactive
experience it was actually a really fun
show
um I do a couple of jokes and then I
just have to have a conversation with a
drunk there was actually a guy in the
crowd who got kicked out
and he wasn't with anybody else he was
by himself
like he was he was basically the best
Drinker of all of his friends is what I
figured out because somebody just I'm in
the middle of my joke and somebody just
yelled security security and they
immediately made a beeline over and I
see them grabbing this guy to you know
escort him out and usually at that point
there's either at least one other person
with them screaming that it was [__]
and there wasn't
he walked out by himself and there was
just one empty chair and uh I think
that's when I finally put it together
and I was like uh oh okay now I get it
you guys are the guys that I saw
drinking six hours ago
out on the street and everybody laughed
it was one of those crowds that would
laugh at the jokes but they would really
laugh when I would snap and tell them
how [__] drunk and how much they're
not paying attention then they would
really laugh
um
but hopefully it was still a good show
there was a few people that was like oh
I wish I could have so in front of a
sober crowd so I kind of felt bad about
some of that [__] but
um
I don't know it reminded me of my days
when I was working my way up
as a comedian
and um
just watching somebody go on in front of
you having to deal with the crowd but
they weren't like bartnik like a
seasoned vet so they were able to handle
it like they were a new comic like I was
and you would watch them going up just
person after person just bombing
and you'd be just thinking like oh my
God oh my God and you just try to come
up with a game plan what am I going to
do what joke am I going to open with
what am I going to say to that guy that
guy says anything to me like back then I
used to I used to have to plan out [__]
that I was gonna say rather than just go
with the frustration of the moment in
the moment and um
when you'd go up there if you bomb two
you just go home so [__] defeated and
angry but if you actually won if you
actually turned the room around
it was just the greatest [__] feeling
like you felt like uh
I don't know he felt like you wouldn't
you were on point of some platoon and
somehow you didn't get [__] whacked I
don't know I don't know what I'm talking
about here so anyways
um
this is like big time Wine Country out
here and
um we played bouncing back here old add
bill here we played that theater last
night it was just some of the greatest
[__] people
backstage
I've been with like our bus driver ran
into somebody else that he knew back
when he used to I guess I didn't know
our bus driver used to drive the Allman
Brothers
and um I should have known he did
because he was [__] cool as [__] and
if you get a cool bus driver those guys
work all the time we get some [__]
weirdo you know what I mean they used to
drive like you know
I don't know Millie Vanilli has some
[__] right so um
him and the other guys are just sitting
there
and um
we're hanging out and they had this
unbelievably gorgeous long
dining room table
and it was one of those modern rustic is
what they call it was built from wood
from an old ship
and then and then the legs were made out
of metal
and the table was just indestructible
what I loved about it
is when you have a table like that you
can spill [__] on it you can literally
use it as a cutting board if you wanted
to and
um you know I should give you guys the
name of that [__] place
um
I guess they're expensive as [__]
health
but uh I've been looking for a dining
room table because we have this awful
just round one we got it from our
neighbors and then we paid this guy to
refinish it
and uh
my wife because she's so [__]
creative had these this design carved
into it that was the same design of this
panel thing that was at our wedding she
had oh Jesus Christ
I just realized there's no way she's
getting rid of that table so well I
guess I'm not buying a table from these
[__] people but uh if you guys would
like
a really great [__] table cocas Deco
is it's
c-o-k-a-s-d-i-k-o I believe and they're
in Santa Rosa California
and they make tables all different sizes
this was like what I loved about this
table was it was big enough that entire
an entire band could come in because
there's a lot of music acts that played
at this venue you could just come in
everybody could sit down granted if they
still got along
um
and these people like they had this
unbelievable spread and they had glasses
of wine and cheese and all that just
giving you the whole experience
because most of the times you know as
you're traveling you don't get to have
the experience like I wanted to go to
bizarre guitar and gun shop and I just
didn't have the time to get over there
um after I went over to get the barbecue
um you know we eat a bunch of barbecue
your body just was just like all right
shutting down now dealing with what you
just put like you just put so much
[__] up [__] into your body there's
not enough energy left to keep you awake
so your body's just like all right
powering down you know it's like when
you put your laptop on sleep mode like
that's what your body does to you like
yeah that's why you know black people
call it the itis I don't know what white
people call it you know whatever the
[__] it is it's like uh I learned that
from Charlie Murphy I told this story
before I gotta tell it again
Charlie Murphy and Donnell Rawlings we
were on a tour called uh the rich [__]
tour
and that was from uh when Don L Donnell
was the guy that did that I'm rich [__]
that would scream at the end of the
Chappelle show so
um
you know they used to always just sit
there breaking balls breaking balls
breaking balls you know making fun of my
clothes and all that type of [__] and uh
it was the worst in the morning you know
what I mean because I'd wake up you know
hung over whatever and these guys were
like a couple of kids they just woke up
like we like they weren't drinking with
me the night before
um I don't say taking multivitamins or
what right
um
so one day I was just [__] I didn't
want to deal with it and we had this
long drive from Chicago all the way up
to like Mount Vernon I don't even
[__] Mount Vernon is New York I can't
remember somewhere like it was like a
two hour drive
and I knew that they were going to be
loud and breaking my balls and I went
extra hard I didn't want to deal with it
and I was standing out there
we had this [__] car service right
this old ass limo I remember that are
there any new limos by the way they're
always [__] old as [__]
um this old ass [__] literally would
look like the thing was from like the
80s this Old Town Car right
and I'm standing there going oh my God I
don't want to deal with these guys
they're going to be loud as [__] and I
looked down the street and I saw Popeyes
and I was just like [__] this because
they had taught me about the itis
because Donnell was eating so bad
Donnell was literally buying hot dogs
at like gas stations and he'd eat them
and within [__] five minutes he would
be asleep like his body would just power
down dealing with the poison he just put
in so I went down the street went in
there and got this giant bucket of
Popeyes
chicken with [__] mashed potatoes and
biscuits and they came walking up
and I was like hey guys I got us some
food
they were like all right man thanks
thanks and they start eating it and I'm
just sitting there nursing like one
drumstick and they ate that [__] and
like within [__] 20 minutes they were
both passed out
and I just sat there with a [__]
shit-eating grin and just wrote in total
silence
up to [__] whatever the [__] we were
going so there you go if you're ever in
a car and you got a loud friend or
something like that a legal way to drug
them is you just get some really bad
fast food because it's poison it's just
all trans fats wow I I in my own selfish
way I poisoned two really good friends
of mine I temporarily
poisoned them
so I could just sit there you know
and enjoy myself as I rode up you know
what I mean
and is it slightly racist that I went
and got a bucket of chicken for two
African Americans in defense of me it's
the first one that I saw
it was the first thing that I saw
oh [__] no anyways
moving on what are we up to here
32 32 and 19th 51 minutes oh we're
closing in on it there
um
oh Jesus Christ I am oh Jesus Christ I
haven't even done the [__]
letters for this week I'm I'm out of it
I'm out of it here where the hell did it
go is this them
all right let's let's listen to me read
out loud one last time here oh my God
you know what I almost forgot to talk
about do you know I watched the end of
the US Open
and watch that poor bastard
potting for eagle
he's with Wayne Gretzky's daughter Wayne
Gretzky is in the crowd a man who has
his name on the cup four times a man who
is a champion
and you saw Gretzky had a big smile on
his face like yeah buddy here we go you
sink this [__]
you go top shelf with this thing it was
a long putt and the guy didn't he didn't
sink it so it's like all right whatever
and then he had a three foot Putt and I
had to leave I had to run out to go do
my show and I shut off the TV assuming
he was going to sink the three foot pot
and then there was going to be a
playoffs that I could watch
you know before my show I guess it would
have been today they would have played
like a whole nother round of golf or
some [__] I guess is how it works so I
shut the TV off thank God I did
and as I'm going out
I was I was going out to to the bus my
phone starts blowing up
and people were some versie wrote oh my
God
that just made me sick
and I thought at first they were talking
about
they were talking about the uh
you know him missing the the eagle pot
right
um
I get this message from a buddy of mine
he wrote holy [__] [__]
that's just awful what does Gretzky say
there and I wrote back did he miss the
birdie putt too and he just wrote yes
like 20 [__] s's he just lost
and I wrote oh no he said miss the
three-footer coming back up unreal
all-time putting choke it's shocking did
you see and I wrote I'm so glad I missed
the second Miss I ran out to the car to
go over to the show I assume he hit it
and I'd watch the playoff and then I
wrote golf is [__] devastating
and he wrote playoff at Us open as 18
holes on Monday for you people are
really into golf
um
golf is absolutely emotionally [__]
emotionally [__] devastating I still
don't think it's a sport it's the most
devastating [__] activity
like the first Masters I ever sat down
and watched wire to wire I watched Kenny
Perry Fall Apart
on 17 and 18 and then go to the playoffs
and [__] lose
to that that cool ass Argentinian dude I
just
I can't get over
how [__] devastating what kills me is
this
it's the thing it's just a complete mind
[__]
it's the biggest mind [__] out there I
believe in that kid though even though
he missed those two things I believe
that kid's a stud he's going to come
back and I feel bad that everyone's
gonna say he's a big [__] choker and
all that like they've ever dealt with
any sort of pressure like that so
whatever his [__] name is I'm not
into golf
um I got empathy for you I believe in
you you're gonna be back and uh it's
only going to make you stronger and just
the fact that he could actually
just not break down into tears right
there on National Television he probably
did later on that night and there's
nothing wrong with that I would have
just when I missed it I would have just
let not even like threw my club down I
would have just let go of it you know
that's even worse that's when you're
devastated when you can't even make your
muscles work anymore you're so sad you
can't even you can't even hold anything
you just let go
it'd be [__] hilarious and you don't
even finish your putt you just [__]
kick it with your foot I don't give a
[__] you just
you have to be carried off like you
remember when James Brown would do that
thing and they'd bring the [__] coat
over to him like they have to do that
except it's a little golf Poncho and the
golf umbrella
and they're just bringing you into
somebody's patting you on the chest like
come on Bill come on I would have done
that
so just the fact that he could he had to
walk out in front of all those people
with their heads high and you know they
were all looking at them
in some way a lot of them were loving it
because they never made it to a U.S open
so uh
I don't know just the fact that he was
[__] in there Percy actually wrote
that was so devastating the guy who won
didn't even enjoy it
oh my God it was it's one of the most
brutal [__] things
you know it was right up there with
watching the Seahawks throw the ball and
have it get intercepted
but at least then
like the devastation of that it spread
across 40 men
you know what I mean who can be all
devastated together as opposed to golf
it's just you by yourself there's no
defense trying to pick the ball off or
guess what you're doing jumping around
it's just you and three feet of grass
another one of my buddies was [__]
on the [__] what the golf course
looked like he goes dude that Golf
Course looks like my backyard
I hated it at first but after a while I
kind of liked it I thought it was kind
of a badass course man it looked like uh
they stopped in the middle of a war and
decided to play 18 holes because they
had like the gallery they were in like
these look like these ruins these
buildings are some [__] that have been
um
torn up anyways let's get to the
questions here for the week uh Bill
where are all the John Wayne's this is
from a lady uh hello Bill I'm a big fan
I hope this gets to you me and my
husband take the drive from Austin to
Houston visiting his dad in the hospital
quite often uh oh man that's sad I hope
he gets better or I don't know I hope
there's something in there that's better
that just made me sad anyways the drive
can can feel long but we cut in cut it
in half with your podcast oh there we go
we get good laughs and we don't have to
talk to each other I'm ready to get your
opinion I may be wrong but I'm open to
hear what you think I wanted to have a
pedicure on my birthday I dragged my
husband with me it's it is the best
place to get a foot and calf massage
he's never had a pedicure so I wanted
for him to experience it with me he was
not a fan he didn't feel like his feet
were being touched by another what he
didn't like his feet being touched by
another man ah oh God
another man giving you a calf massage
oh Jesus Christ
when is this month gonna end
my God the uncomfortableness of this
month
Jesus Christ yeah he thinks women try to
emasculate Men by having them get waxed
spray tan and have pedicures
he's always referencing men in Hollywood
by saying where are all the John Wayne's
I wasn't trying to emasculate him but to
give him a new experience and hope that
he would enjoy a little relaxation he
wasn't into it tell me if you get
pedicures and if you enjoy them
you're great go [__] yourself uh no I
don't get pedicures
this is the thing men are not allowed
to enjoy any sensual experience unless
it's with the female like women can just
sit there and let another woman touch
their feet and massage their calves and
be like oh my God that feels so good
thank you Stacy
you know we're not allowed to do some
the thing about it is is guys we're like
when I picture guys
remember remember those old Square TVs
that you had that's like what a guy is
physically would just like these blocks
you know
and with just like would not like that
I'm getting grossed out
this is just gross and maybe I'm [__]
immature but no you know something
I think
I don't know maybe I'm wrong here uh
this is when we need Nia because she'll
[__] soften what I'm gonna say here
what the [__] are you doing to your man
here
don't you want that guy to see [__]
red the second anybody an intruder comes
in
you're killing that off of him
he's just gonna grab some [__] lamp
and start smashing it over somebody's
[__] head if they're coming to your
house if he's getting a calf massage
and getting his toes [__] painted
what are you doing to him
you're rehabbing a pit bull here for no
[__] reason he's fine the way he is
oh my God
no you know something I think I one time
I did get a pedicure I get when I was on
the [__] rich [__] tour you know
something
black dudes
we'll get manicures
they'll get manicures I think it was a
manicure did I get a I know I got a
pedicure one time I think I was with Nia
I think I blocked it up yeah we were in
New York I got a pedicure and then the
lady
was rubbing my calves and all it did was
make me want to get a [__] you know a
happy ending
it was just like yeah keep going keep
going skip the thighs get to the finish
line
um
I I don't know
I don't even remember the experience I
just remember I did it because she asked
me to do it and I did it and I remember
laughing I remember being really
immature and when I dip my feet into the
[__] water it just was making me
laugh I was like I almost lost control
of myself because it was just something
that was so [__] foreign to me
um
and I was sitting and then the more I
laughed the more Nia was laughing and
she just kept laughing going what it's
nice it's nice and I just kept laughing
going what are you doing to me
um
and then afterwards I don't know but I
will say afterwards my toes nails were
as clean as they've ever [__] been
but uh you know I'll you know I'll just
get one of those [__] 50 Cent scrub
brushes uh I'll just say can you leave
them alone
you know what I mean
you you can I understand you're trying
to like give them a nice experience but
like that can go a little too far
and next thing you know
you're wondering what happened to the
man you married
or maybe you're not maybe you're more
involved I don't know maybe women are
more involved I don't [__] know don't
ask me those questions I feel gross
right now all right please explain this
to me
Caitlyn Jenner is receiving an award at
the ESPYs for her courage which is
apparently the greatest thing ever what
they don't tell you is the person who
won't be receiving the award now is
Lauren Hill the girl who is diagnosed
diagnosed with inoperable brain cancer
but Lauren Hill the singer
what she played her first game oh so
this is a has the same name she played
her first game for her college
basketball game after a diagnosis I saw
this
I saw this [__] story and for months
to come she raised over a million
dollars for cancer research she died a
couple of months later so please explain
to me why a guy chopping his dick off is
more courageous than standing up to
cancer
you know I'll tell you why because you
know what at the end of the day it's
Show Business
that's why
it's [__] Show Business
um I know somebody that writes on that
show and I know of something that
happened that I can't say
and someone was in the truck flipping
out that it was going on too long and
all they were thinking about was you
know going like this is the worst
[__] moment in my life
because this person up there I'm not
even gonna say what it was but it's just
it's [__] show business that's why so
they're probably going like oh do we
want to bring the room down
or maybe like well they always have
something about somebody dying on that
show
the the touching moment you know what I
mean but then they're thinking oh
Caitlyn Jenner is really hot right now
has the high Q rating or something like
that that'll give us more
um
I don't know why why why
I don't understand what that award is
I could see if Caitlyn just went out on
one another decathlon
like they kind of given basically
they're giving it to Bruce Jenner in a
way the way they gave [__] uh Martin
Scorsese the Oscar for The Departed
because they [__] up on uh Raging Bull
they didn't give it to him for [__]
good Fellas they owed it to them so I
think they owed Bruce Jenner a [__]
airspeak they never gave it to him it's
like [__] we waited too long because now
Bruce is Caitlyn well maybe we can give
it to her and she can give it to him
through her brain
I don't [__] know I don't produce
shows and by that last [__] horrific
answer you can understand why all right
the age of Technology
dear Billy bomb site I'm an open Miker
in a semi-small city and don't really
expect to get much attention in this
place it that's a great place to start
don't videotape yourself and get better
well videotape yourself but don't upload
it onto YouTube and get you get real
good then move to a better City with
more exposure and then become a monster
anyways
um I recently found out that someone at
an open mic was recording video of
everyone set oh [__]
and put all the capture content onto
their social network page including mine
when I found out that my shitty
undeveloped open micing was on the
internet I was Furious as you should
have been and contacted the individual
that posted it they have since taken
most of the content down but I had a
long argument about this situation with
a different person they argued in
defense of this lady by saying this is
the world we live in now you were in a
public place and that gave her the right
to record you the worst that happens is
that you say something stupid and get
and you get publicity for it any
publicity is good publicity all right
you know what that person is going to be
a [__] hack
um he said my argument is basically that
if she earns any money from my content
then I have a right to be pissed off I
also feel very uneasy thinking about the
possibility of saying something stupid
about a current event and getting Flack
on Twitter just because I thought it was
funny and no one else did yeah and
you're also brand new to Comedy and you
should be allowed to make mistakes uh
with the recent popularity of the app
Periscope and hearing you [__] a little
bit about it I would like to hear your
opinion on this argument
thanks and go shag yourself uh P.S you
still have fans in Nebraska
um
yeah no I'm 100 agreement with you you
should be allowed to develop as an open
micro but you can't get mad at the lady
like they don't understand that what
they're doing could be detrimental
um
and it is the world that we live in
because people do do that but you're you
you are right
um
and I don't understand why everybody
feels like they have to videotape every
[__] moment
of their lives now it's all like it's
almost like they're campaigning for this
office of hey I have the coolest life
like always taking a selfie like you
know this is me an Old Faithful you know
it's so what I'm supposed to look at
like wow this guy [__] goes
everywhere
you know what I mean I I don't I don't
understand it I mean I guess I do that
don't I do that
I took a picture of me and uh well it
wasn't a selfie but me and bartnick when
we were in Reno with that iconic sign
I don't know but I wish people wouldn't
do it at Live Events
um especially when there's jokes because
the new jokes become old jokes but um I
think that's gonna end because they're
now
coming out with these these businesses
popping up for entertainers where
they're going to block people's cell
phones during the performance which is
uh
which is pretty awesome I think if it's
like up to the artist although I'm also
guilty because I watch all this [__]
that people videotape to Stevie Ray
Vaughan and that type of thing
um and then you get to enjoy the
performance but you know
I don't think I'm going out on a limb to
say that you're not at your Stevie Ray
Vaughan level of being a stand-up yet
it'd be nice if you could be allowed to
develop
um I people have recorded my shows and
whenever I reach out to them on YouTube
they always take him down I never get
mad at them I understand that they're
not in the business and they don't get
but that what they're doing actually
hurts me on some level
um so just deal with it whatever [__]
that dude hey this is the world we live
in
you know those people who don't get mad
that the government can record all your
phone conversations it's just like well
hey you know if you're not doing
anything wrong what's the problem those
[__] people anyways I gotta I gotta
wrap this up here because I gotta be on
the bus in 10 minutes
now roommates lady wants to move in
uh hey Billy Bob Ginger tits Jesus
Christ enough with the redhead jokes can
you guys go with something new it's
getting [__] boring here
um my roommate of five years has this
new lady who is cool but off the bat
seems kind of manipulative he told me
that she's getting kicked out of her
place and she wants to move into our
two-bedroom apartment in New York City
which isn't that big as you would know
for three months she wants to move there
for three months the rent will be split
three ways they are planning on moving
in together after she stays for three
months do I accept the cheaper rent or
tell her to take a hike by the way
they've been dating for six months you
rule go [__] yourself no that
manipulative [__] is going to end up
convincing her boy boyfriend you're
going to be the guy who's gonna leave
because she's not going to leave they're
going to ask you to leave and you're
like [__] you I'm not leaving and then
it's going to be two against one and
your life's gonna be miserable do not on
any level allow her to move in say this
is a two-bedroom apartment this is for
two people not for three it affects my
quality of life there's not enough money
in the [__] Universe for me to
compromise
my um
my quality of life so no
that's it no
and you stand by that and [__] him
okay and [__] her
and then that's it and you won't have to
deal with that situation and with any
luck he'll [__] move out you'll get
another roommate and you won't be
involved in that situation then you'll
have more power because then you'll have
been there longer than the other person
all right that is one of the easiest
questions ever do not on any level let
her move in six months in your
codependent [__] [__]
go [__] yourself